have you noticed one of the many things
different about the holidays this year
the ads oh
hi santa oh good morning
you know what i can't even fake it look
after the year
we just had the usual gifts are just not
going to cut it
so we have to find something else and
fast that's all figure it out
good luck okay so you might not
recognize the face but i'll bet you
recognize that voice that's steve carell
yay steve carell santa in a new
commercial vexfinity working remotely of
course
our consumer investigative correspondent
that's anna warner reports on how
advertisers have changed their approach
because of the pandemic
flip on the tv and you may see more ads
like these
a girl and her grandmother separated by
glass
[Music]
postal carriers essential workers
diligently bringing the mail
a year like 2020 calls for a different
kind of holiday advertising
says new york times advertising writer
tiffany shu
how do we nod to the fact that everyone
is still cooped up at home people are
still social distancing the holidays are
not going to look like they normally do
while also striking the balance of
saying
you guys can still shop you guys can
still celebrate let's deck the halls
over video calls this walmart ad
acknowledges the current reality of
social distancing
and mask wearing but not every company
is emphasizing the pandemic
take lifetime which is owned by a e
networks
and kfc for example the hell are you
mario lopez is
colonel sanders they're rolling out this
15-minute
mini movie featuring mario lopez over
the weekend
it's branded content featuring kfc's
star in a typical lifetime made for tv
style drama david disoccio is with a
e networks i think the project is done
with a wink we know again we know what
the audience loves
kfc knows what the audience loves so
we're giving them all of that it's kind
of a little bit of an escape
andrea zamanski is with kfc
at the end of the day this is about
brand promotion it is about
telling a bit of our brand story in a
fun way
not all new approaches are proving to be
popular
hershey's is getting some negative
feedback for changing its iconic
holiday kisses ad this year it cuts to a
family
making cookies there's a lot riding on
the success of these ads
it's it's make or break for a lot of
companies they know that if they don't
hit the
exact right tone with these ads their
consumers are going to be all over them
with complaints
publicly
well shu says that hershey's later said
it would run both the new ad
and the traditional ad but goes to show
you that striking this delicate balance
right now with advertising can be a
little tricky
anthony yeah it's such an interesting
year
in every respect even christmas is
complicated anna thank you